well we got a little baby naming drama i
want your take on uh the sun reports a
woman in the uk posted this dilemma
online she and her husband they're about
to have a little baby and they finally
after discussing it they finally picked
out a name miles which is such a cute
name the only problem is when she told
her best friend the best friend totally
gasped
because miles is the name that she had
picked out for her future son now her
friend is not pregnant right now though
but she plans one day she wants to have
a baby but she seemed genuinely
disappointed that you know her friend
had snatched the name so this woman
wanted to know should she feel guilty
right now for planning to name her son
miles or she just should she just go
like forward with it i have a strong
opinion but i'm curious
audience guests uh raise your hand if
you think she should
go with the name
raise your hand if you're if you think
she shouldn't name her son miles because
her friend likes it
nobody okay
all right all right so i think this is a
one-way street here yeah well what about
you what do you think
no
she shouldn't she shouldn't back off she
should just stay stick with miles no
matter what a friend says that you're
not even pregnant
and how about instead of making my big
moment
not about you
why couldn't they both be miles do you
guys remember in like elementary school
i had so many jennifers in my class
there was like jennifer w jennifer d
jennifer c i still have one of them
saved as jennifer c in my phone yeah
like and we all were fine so there can
be two miles chill out girl plus you
know i have a baby yet oh yeah right
i know all right and finally a pic from
drew's little yellow book it's the
little yellow book that i create every
week
for you because i love to share and this
week um is very important today kicks
off black history month and we are
celebrating with putting the spotlight
on
girl wonder they are a non-profit doing
incredible work to support young women
of color reaching for the careers of
their dreams and their extensive
mentorship program pairs young women
with professionals for special
one-on-one tutelage and relationships
and we're donating a thousand dollars to
that incredible team at girl wonder to
support you and thank you for all that
you do to find out more about them and
how you can get involved please go to
our website at
thedrewberrymarshow.com or the little
yellow book
[Music]
you